Hello reboots are symptomatic of
a fundamental lack of originality
in hollywood have you no shame here's your
check for the animaniacs reboot you sellouts
it's
all right guys there's a lot of pressure on
our first lines wait don't make sure it's good
first maybe something reminiscent of the first
season 22 years later and i'm still a knockout
i've tried online dating but i keep getting
catfished how do i know she's even real
this tablet contains the
sum of all human knowledge
all human knowledge and one easy to swallow tablet
quantum mechanics quinoa wraps
queen bay we've missed so much
oh sounds like an odyssey
my sandwich
just where i left it gekko turn on the black light
nothing unusual there gee brian what
do you want to do tonight the same
thing we do every night pinkie try
to take over the world we found party
i am the pegasus i come bearing
horrible tidings of war from the
beginning oh yeah yeah less
talking more flappy totally
now the adoration pours in
nerve
helen this species of cartoon
has been extinct since 1998
i mean these haven't been seen on tv
since the golden era of animation and what
it's it's the warner brothers
that's yeah that oh yeah yeah he did it that
that that that crazy son of a gun actually did it
clean vectored outlines wide screen format these
don't look like reruns uh well uh they're not i
reanimated them we are gonna make a fortune with
this show how zany are they oh uh to the max
of course then there's a pinky in the
brain pinky in the brain you said you're
bringing back pinky in the brain mm-hmm say it
again we're bringing back pinky in the brain
put your head between your knees
where are they going home welcome to animaniacs
Welcome back everyone surprise surprise this
is going to be my new Animaniacs trailer video
there's a bunch of easter eggs obviously they
brought the show back for a couple seasons so
i'll explain what's going on with this but
this is the most nostalgic thing that they
probably could have done so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
the series is premiering november 20th the
entire voice cast is back so creatively the
show looks exactly like the original run i don't
really consider myself an animation channel but
there are just some animated series that seem
to transcend the genre that i just think are so
amazing that i try to do videos for like rick
and morty avatar the last airbender this is
also just one of those series that was just
so iconic and mind-blowing back in the day
and in the same way that they used the original
series to parody pop culture and make fun of
everyone including themselves breaking the fourth
ball deadpool style they're still doing that very
much very on point you probably saw a bunch
of easter eggs during this trailer footage the
reason why the gravestones read 1998 while they're
singing the classic intro song is because 1998 was
when the show was cancelled and now they're rising
from the grave so to speak the voice cast are all
very prolific so they've been doing animaniacs
conventions and reunions ever since then
on a regular basis they've continued to do the
voices for the characters in funny one-offs they
signed a contract with death for two new seasons
because as you guessed the show was renewed for
two more seasons it's going to be 13 episodes
per season death himself was also a character on
the original show pretty much everybody that they
feature in the trailer is from the original show
they are calling it a reboot but technically
it's just a continuation because it's all the
same people like when they brought young justice
back at warner brothers but i think they wanted
to call it season one instead of calling it season
one billion just so people who are new to the show
can just pick up and not feel like they're missing
a whole bunch of stuff but if you've never seen
the series before i would encourage you to go back
and watch the original there are some of the most
classic episodes of animation you're both mistaken
it is the sophisticated wit and charm of pinky and
the brain that has captured steven's heart as well
as making it the breakaway hit of the wb schedule
they do a bit about redoing the same type of
introduction from the pilot episode don't you feel
old now even though obviously a lot of animation
is intended for younger audiences i feel like most
of the people watching this at first will be older
people who watch the original show back in the day
then we get more pinky in the brain their
spin-off series was amazing back in the day
i almost liked it more than i liked the original
animaniacs series i believe their episodes are
also available on hulu separately right now too
but they originated on the main show as a smaller
bit before they got the spin-off series that's why
they're here in this new main show as you can see
they've updated a lot of the themes the jokes
the references for 2020. the brain has all this
election stuff behind him because it seems like
he's trying to win the presidency in his episode
and pinky talks about online dating like tinder
and getting catfished something that did not exist
22 years ago not catfishing online dating people
have been getting catfished since the dark ages
but he's also using an ipad there are
a couple ipad jokes throughout this too
they make a joke about the online wiki for the
show containing the sum of all human knowledge
wikis also didn't exist 22 years ago at least
in their current form they make a reference to
homer's odyssey because it seems like from a bunch
of the other trailer footage they do an episode
based on greek mythology they make a reference
to yakko's last sandwich that's apparently been
rotting there in the vault for the last 22 years
they do a funny bit about pinkie and the brain's
trademark phrase what do you want to do tonight
the same thing we do every night try to take
over the world but they stopped them short from
actually completing the line dumping the cage full
of foam then they preview a couple of the episodes
that they're doing they make a couple more modern
references for the episodes like my little pony
i'm sure there's going to be a ton of brony jokes
like the pony instead of being all cute launches
into this grand speech about this epic war
that's going on it looks like they have an anime
themed episode then a classic animation themed
episode they feature a ton of other classic
warner brothers characters like yogi bear and
huckleberry hound then they end with an instagram
joke which also didn't exist 20 years ago then
there's a much longer clip of a jurassic park bit
with steven spielberg in the cast of the original
jurassic park movie the bigger reference here for
those of you that didn't watch the original show
is that they're using steven spielberg in his
movie for this parody because steven spielberg
actually helped create the original series when
it debuted in the 90s we were just wondering
who's your favorite even though he himself
didn't always voice his character a steven
spielberg character showed up on the series all
the time they made fun of his movies all the time
he's still an executive producer on the new show
but i don't know if he's still involved with it
creatively so that's them making the joke about
them bringing the dinosaurs back in jurassic park
movie but now they're bringing these animation
dinosaurs back after 22 years if you never saw
the original series or you never saw the pinky in
the brain spin-off series they are amazing be sure
to check them out some of the best episodes of
the show are when they start breaking the fourth
wall and making fun of warner brothers the company
itself like they make fun of the warner brothers
ceo as part of this big episode they make fun of
the corporate culture when they have to defend dr
scratchensniff in a trial for a parking
ticket that he got on the warner brothers lot
most of the stuff they're making fun of though at
the time was current so we're talking about late
90s tv shows and movies like they made fun of the
friends tv show because at the time friends was
the biggest tv show in the world they even did
a mighty morphin power rangers episode because
mighty morphin power rangers was still going on
speaking of reboots they actually just announced
that they're bringing the power rangers back
in brand new tv shows and movies so somebody
behind the scenes is just slamming their fist
on the nostalgia button for bringing stuff back
they had some of the best musical numbers and
songs even if you haven't seen a lot of the
original episodes you've probably seen at least
one of the songs on youtube at some point probably
the most famous one is yakko's world where he
does all the different countries of the world
united states canada mexico panama haiti jamaica
peru republic dominican cuba caribbean greenland
el salvador too so everyone post all your favorite
animaniacs and pinky and the brain references in
the comments below and let me know which other
shows do you actually want to see them bring back
talk about classic animation disney actually just
made a movie called raya in the last dragon that's
basically them doing avatar the last airbender
of the series as a new movie so i might do a
video for that sometime in the next couple
of days but there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those videos
while you wait for everything click here
to learn what's going on with the avatar
the last airbender new netflix series and click
here for the spider-man into the spider-verse 2
teaser trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!